[inaudible]
joining me today is a gorilla journalist,
the head of Project Veritas and the
author of American Prob de James O'keefe.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Great to be here. Long overdue,
I think is the way I'm going to start
this one because you are sort of right in
the center of a lot of the things
that I'm constantly talking about.
So it's good to have you. Great to be
here. Thanks for having me. Okay, so, uh,
before we get into all your work that
I think most of my audience knows,
at least a portion of, I don't think
anyone knows that much about you.
What do we need to know about James
O'keefe, the man? How did he become this,
this rogue reporter and guy that was
unearthing all of the evil things that are
tech overlords are doing to us?
Well, I started in college doing
these undercover tapes. Uh,
I actually started 15 years ago,
started a newspaper in
college called the Centurion.
And I quickly learned that the way to
expose these institutions is to sort of
make them live up to their own principles.
Like the Alinsky tactic.
I'd read rules for radicals by
Saul Alinsky in college and I,
I decided to expose hypocrisy by
making them live up to their own rules.
And I realized that those rules were
race and sex and sort of abortion,
these sort of sacred cow institutions,
planned parenthood and acorn.
And I decided to use hidden cameras.
I went into the dining hall at Rutgers,
I on Saint Patrick's Day and I said that
lucky charms offends my Irish heritage.
They took me seriously and told
us they would remove lucky charms.
Cereal is the first video that I did.
And from there I actually went on
to work with uh, uh, Lila rose,
who you had on the show recently and
some planned parenthood investigations.
Acorn with Andrew Breitbart and I have
done some 200 undercover investigations
in the last 10 years.
I assume as you
do more undercover things and now
you've got other people that are,
that are doing a portion of them,
it gets harder and harder to do as
people know who you are and know the
organization and things
you'd be surprised. I mean at the
moment we read the Society of waste,
fraud and abuse.
I suppose we will win the day,
but people are always
going to be in power,
tends to corrupt and absolute
power corrupts absolutely.
And money and, and, uh,
things that develop.
People all are always going to be corrupt.
So I don't actually wear the
camera these days very often.
I sort of go out into the field to,
to be a leader to the troops.
But for the most part it's,
it's,
we've got dozens of these people across
the United States with wearing these
little cameras. You put them in, you
can put them in a cup for, you know,
you can put them in a book, you can put
them in a watch. And as long as you're,
I ask you if there's more
than four cameras in the
studio right now. Cause I got,
there's a war. There's a few over
there. Yes. Um, but you know,
but as long as there's one party
consenting to the conversation,
as long as that you're,
you're talking to someone,
there's no expectation of privacy.
We would argue.
And we won in federal court in
Massachusetts a few months ago. We,
we changed the law.
So it's,
we believe that secretly recording
someone is a fundamental human right.
It's a constitutional right
because I have no duty.
Keep confidential what you tell me.
So the hidden camera is an extension of
the reporter notebook and the cameras
capture things that words don't, I mean
cameras capture, intonation, inflection.
And so we believe that this is a kind
of transparency revolution and there's a
movement of people doing
this in a weird way.
It is sort of depressing reality.
Like when I've watched some of your
videos and you get engineers at these
companies and we're going to, we're
going to talk about all of them, uh,
to admit things that we all are sort
of thinking or true related to shadow
banning or d boosting where everything
else, there's a piece of me,
even when they're, they're tipping off
the information that I suspect is true.
There's a piece of me that's
like, this is, this is,
there's something sort of depressing
about this that this is what we've been
left with. Like we have
to go after, you know,
mid level and sometimes low level
engineers and sometimes the bigger ones.
But because there's no transparency
when it comes to these companies.
So it feels almost depressing to me.
Does that mean, does that make sense?
I think the way that I would put it,
like it's unfortunate, I suppose I,
some people call it depressing,
some people say it. Could
we confirm suspicions?
I would say that what we do is
summon righteous indignation, uh,
at the tragedies in society,
including in these organizations
because they run so counter to what were
spoonfed the narratives that
were spoon fed by the media,
by the powers that be so Hidden Camera
Journal and investigative reporting,
whether it's hidden camera or print
does that it summons what I to Tarbell
termed as righteous indignation at the
tragedies. And it kind of, you know,
most people, I would say 80%, there's
a sort of consensus around what we do.
People say, well that's wrong
or they deny it. So Twitter, uh,
Twitter lobbyist in
Congress under oath said,
we do not shadow banned when his
engineer clearly said what we do.
Do is shadow band and we,
I don't know if we do that anymore.
That's what the engineer said. Clearly
meaning that he had shadow banned people.
So, um, it's, it's perjury to
lie under oath and, and you know,
these hidden camera videos really show
people what's going on at angers people.
I think the world is more
polarized than it was 10 years ago.
So maybe that 80% consensus
is, is, is going down.
Are you worried at all though that will
always be videotaping each other and
that there will be nothing that's private.
I mean, even now if I go out to dinner,
like I'm aware that I'm some level of
a public person and sometimes people
recognize me and sometimes I was at the
airport and it was very obvious to me
that the guy,
I was sitting with somebody,
but that the guy next to me clearly knew
who I was and he was on his computer
and the whole time I can think of this
guy could be recording me, you know? And,
and just all like just this
endless big brother thing.
Even if the intentions of what you're
doing. I do believe to be good.
Are you just worried about just that
general state of we're all going to be
recording each other all the time?
There will be nothing private.
I'm not worried at all.
I mean there's an element of risk every
time you interact with strangers and you
talk to them, as long as there's one
party present to the conversation,
we would argue that it's ethical.
And again,
we think that camera's visuals are
merely an extension. I mean I could,
I could disseminate what
you tell me in private.
I could write it down and shout it from
the rooftops opt ins and clarity wrote
the jungle. He saw everything and then
he ran back to his hotel and wrote,
wrote it all down.
So surely society would would,
would rather a situation
where I accurately capture
what it is that you told me
and I have to use cameras. They indemnify
me because people call me a liar.
They say that didn't happen.
So I have to,
I have to record the
incidents because they would,
they would say that it did not
happen the way that I reported it.
And they also think that I think that
there are lines that we can't cross.
We don't go into people's bedrooms, we
try to stay away from the really personal,
intimate, you know, sexual
details about, about people.
But this is a revolution that's
aimed at the power structure at this
establishment, the powers that be not
against private citizens. And we don't.
And I think there was a duty,
there is a responsibility
that investigative reporters
have not to put people on
blast unless it really meets
a compelling public interest.
So you mentioned you started this in,
in college.
What was tipping you off to like that
there was something wrong with the media?
I mean,
what made you go,
I gotta go in there and say I'm Irish
and I'm offended by Leptin charms.
Like what really was happening that
you were seeing that led to that? Well,
I was in at Rutgers University in New
Jersey and it was so the political
correctness was run a muck like
most schools and all these daily,
there's something bad happening with the
grease trucks please. The grease trucks,
trucks, trucks, please tell
me that they're okay. It's
for those who don't know,
they're these trucks at Rutgers and it's
like they're all in the parking lot and
uh, and you get real fat real quick,
older, your collar, there was something,
you know what? There was something wrong
with the gross trucks. They had duct,
they'd put duct tape. This is
in 2005, over these sandwiches.
Am I allowed to curse on them?
There was one of them called the fat,
the fat bitch and the fat,
a dyke and other words that
were offensive. And um,
they had put duct tape over the names
because these words were considered
offensive. That's what was the, like what
compelled me to try to ban lucky charms.
So I said, this is ridiculous. I also
had professors who were Stalinists.
I had professors who were telling me
how great communist Communism was.
And I was not political,
but I read the New York Times every day
front to back in college in the dining
hall. I was sort of an
introverted guy and I'd read,
read the paper and I was just, I said,
this doesn't accurately capture the world.
This doesn't, this doesn't tell
people what's really going on. So I,
I felt compelled to do something
about it and it wasn't comfortable.
It's not comfortable to confront
people with cameras and, you know,
get into their faces.
But I was willed to do it because I
believed in the cause and, and the,
the kind of Alinsky, uh, methodology,
which is to make them accountable
to their own principles. You know,
you had these Marxist professors driving
Bentleys and BMWs and had a little muck
raking newspaper and it was
like lifestyles of the rich
and Marxist. Right, right.
You know, track these people down. I
just feel that most people that do this,
most insiders inside these companies
coming to us now have what I call it
justice complex.
They think that there are things wrong
with the world and they feel compelled to
do something about it. It's
hard to explain. Uh, but
you know, I'm sure you know,
people who have this complex and these
people are willing to basically jump on a
grenade to wear a camera,
to film their employer.
Some cases violating their
own nondisclosure agreement
because they believe the
public has a right to
know what they're seeing.
Are you shocked at the amount of people
at these big tech companies who now are
willing to speak?
Because I mean I know insiders
that I get some information from,
I mean I'm talking about Google,
Facebook,
Twitter like that really these things
have become so huge that now their own
people inside them are going, Whoa,
what, what did we help create here?
I'm not sure. Got a frack,
a Frankenstein Monster.
I mean I have you been to Menlo Park and
you go to San Francisco and I was there,
cause I did this Facebook story,
this insider inside Facebook and I went
to try to locate these engineers and ask
them for comment.
And there were just these buses,
just hundreds of buses filled
with millennials and end,
if you go to the campus, people are
sort of driving around these bicycles.
The best word I can describe
it as their minions.
It's to sort of this little totalitarian
little mini state within a state.
And it's just a group think or,
well Ian Place and I,
and I guess the,
the word that it was described to me by
the insights that they're all minions.
They're very intelligent people but they
don't have a lot of common sense and
there, and I, and I went there,
I was amazed by this Menlo
Park campus buses of,
of young people being bused in.
And I think that it doesn't surprise
me that people are willing to blow the
whistle because there's more to
life than, than making, you know,
a quarter million dollars a
year and working for these
companies. People want to,
people want to do something. One of the
things that I get told all the time,
what can I do? And, and there aren't a lot
of choices for people. You know, you can,
you can watch the shows,
you can buy the books,
but some people want to actually
participate in this country. And,
and solutions are increasingly, you
know, outside the scope of government,
the legislative process does not
seem to solve things. So there's,
there needs to be in a
different counterweight.
There needs to be a different solution
and I would say that 0.001% of people are
like put a camera on me. That's a lot of
people by the way. Yeah, right, right,
right. We're talking about a lot
of people at the end of the day.
So when did you realize that because
you've mostly focused or at least I think
the the,
the work that has gotten you the most
attention has been related to the tech
companies, not necessarily going
after politicians or academics per se,
although you've done some of that.
When did you realize that focusing
on the tech companies was,
was really the thing that was going to
strike the chord with most people because
that's what it seems to be. Well, because
I think the media has all the power.
I think that I've known this for ever
since I started this endeavor was that the
media has so much more
power than people realize.
Everyone knows the media is powerful,
but I think that people fear the
humiliating power of the press.
I think the press,
including the big tech companies
have more power than government.
They are more powerful
than all three branches of
government, executive, judicial,
legislative branch. So somehow we
need to hold these people accountable.
They're not a cat, they're not held
accountable by anybody who elects them.
And I don't know what the
solutions are. People say, well,
what should they be regulated?
I think they should be transparent
or there will need to be regulated,
but they have to at least
not deceive the people.
So because the media has all the power,
I,
I wrote this book called American Proverb
de and I believe that people don't
know that they're being lied to by CNN
and the New York Times and they don't
know that they're being d boosted in
shadow, banned by Twitter and Facebook.
And I think these companies need
to tell you that they're doing it.
It's not so bad if they take
your account down and restore it.
But the thing that's really scary about
the d boosting and the shadow banning is
that you don't know that it is
happening to you. And I have to see it.
You can kind of feel it.
There are times when everything I'm
doing is on fire or then sometimes where
it's just like nothing happens and those
usually have a certain political bent
to them and then you end up really feeling
like you're in a mental institution
because if you don't have
evidence of anything,
I don't want to be the guy that's
running around and screaming,
everything's a conspiracy and they're
coming after me and leaving the rest.
We're doing this on youtube right now.
And even when you do have evidence,
like we have video tape after
tape of people inside Twitter,
including the Twitter direct messaging
guy saying that they have certain key
words and they consider
to be a Russian Bot.
If you tweet about God
guns and the American flag,
most of these engineers are not,
some of them are not American citizens.
Then they don't share American values.
And this individual says,
if you tweet about fly, he's who
talks like that, who talks about God,
you must be a Russian Bot.
I have the videotape and they still,
they still say it's fake. So, you
know, I think that what, you know,
it's one of those things where people
need to see this stuff and the lead and
that just want these companies
to be honest about what
they're doing. They just,
I just want them to be honest. That's
why I want to be honest though. I mean,
we want them to be honest, right? So I'm
with you. I want them to be honest and,
and the reason I apply
as much pressure on them,
on Twitter and youtube particularly is
because I want them to be better. Right?
Like I, I always say this, it's
like I've got a million subscribers.
I put out a television quality
show on Youtube for free,
and I don't even have an email
address to someone at Youtube.
I have no contact at someone at Youtube.
Like that's rigid. Timidly crazy.
They're a huge company
that offers a product.
I'm a user of the product that helps make
them money through advertising and all
that stuff. I can't even
get a human there, but I,
but I don't think I can force
them to be better. Right. Well,
it's the job of investigative reporting
to hold people accountable to, to,
to test and affirm what
is an outrage to people.
And I think that you can't lie
under oath. You can't. I mean,
Mark Zuckerberg said in,
in Congress last spring,
some things that may be contradicted by
some of the documents we've unearthed,
there are laws against perjury and the,
and what people have to remember is I
don't have a position on whether these
companies should be regulated.
I honestly don't know what should be done.
I do know that people need to know
what is happening inside the companies,
and I think that because
they're so powerful, people
have no idea you when you,
when you digest content from
CNN and the New York Times,
all that stuff gets filtered
through Facebook. In fact,
when I did the Facebook story,
I was shocked by some people in
media telling me, while I don't know,
I love the story, but I don't
know if I can cover it. Why not?
Because we derive most of
our revenue from Facebook.
The same thing happened during
the 2016 election. When I,
when I did the Hillary Clinton tapes
and the Bob Creamer resigned. I mean,
people have to remember that these
companies are publicly traded companies.
They get their broadcast
license from the FCC.
In some circumstances there
sort of entanglements.
There's a symbiotic relationship between
the corporate press and the government.
And for those reasons,
again,
to go back to the campaign
to recruit insiders,
it's going to require citizens.
It's gonna require outsiders to blow
the whistle because no one in the
government is going to do it. Indeed,
many of them around the take. Okay.
So let's just do each platform or one at
a time. So you just mentioned Facebook.
So let's go to phase.
What do,
what do we need to know about what's
going on with the Facebook algorithm and
the way they're banning
people in suspending people
and the rest of it? Well,
I can tell you what our insider told us,
saying I can,
I try to only speak about
the things that I know.
100% in the insider was
working in the content review,
uh,
the content review tool at Facebook.
And she was a contractor
for the company and she, uh,
leaked us documents inside the company
showing I guess what would be called as a
de boost of a live stream video.
And she said she specifically saw
this on Steven Crowder's page. Um,
uh,
she saw it on a few other pages.
She took a screenshot of a Mike Cernovich
page and on the page it says I action
live distribution.
This was apparently some type of algorithm
written too from what we could see,
two to reduce content that
was suicidal or violent,
but none of these
individuals were talking or,
or doing anything that
would rise to that level.
And now there's two different parts of
Facebook. People need to understand.
There is a task system where it seems
like Facebook after the election hired
hundreds if not thousands of people to
monitor. And they do a fairly good job.
If your page gets taken down,
it can be reinstated,
you can file a complaint and they,
they have a pretty good process.
But then there's another part of Facebook
that this insight or told us about or
these were,
this algorithm was occurring.
And it was occurring automatically and
they were identifying certain key words.
So she leaks us this troll report,
it's called a troll report.
And after the election, Facebook decided
to Chino to get more involved in,
in,
in things,
I guess they didn't like the outcome of
the election and maybe that's what this
was. It was really about, I mean,
independent people having an impact on,
on society.
They don't,
they don't like that and they're
in hitting needs more control.
So they had this troll report.
There are certain key words, uh,
words that we're not racist or,
or problematic really,
but they were words that were appropriated
by, by right wing meme culture,
words like lulls and normy.
And even the, even the, the,
the MSM mainstream media
was in this troll report.
Since typically right wingers
use MSM more than the left.
And these are just words or phrases or
acronyms that usually are just men in
meme. Funny Sharon, silly ways. These
are not a threat to democracy. Msm,
mainstream media is not an implication
of racism. Well, they also blow up,
brought up Lauren Chen, they,
they, they brought her up. It was,
she was in there as an example of
someone who is needs to be dealt with.
Visa VI, the, the, uh, the product
intervention at Facebook. And I don't,
I don't know, I'm not aware of any
of any activities or problems with,
with her videos. I mean, she's just
someone who's sharing her mind on youtube.
I'm not sure what order
we're putting these up in,
but I've got Laura and chat and
coming in here. That's so cool.
Well that says it's a cosmic coincidence.
So, so she likes us these documents,
uh, we put the story out instantly.
What happens is the press, uh,
the verge was the name of the outlet
comes out, comes to Facebook's defense.
It always happens, by the way,
we did the story on Twitter.
And instantly buzzfeed comes out of the
Twitter says they don't do this because
that's not, that's not journalism. I mean,
Twitter says the job of
investigative reporting is to,
is to question what they tell you.
But it's always the case when we do these
videos that people come out and they
said, well, they say
they don't do this. Um,
and they came to Facebook's defense. But
the truth is these documents were real.
And the two engineers that we interviewed,
a guy named Sagey Yamamoto and Danny,
Ben,
David actually confronted these guys on
the street in San Francisco with a film
crew because no one would
give me any answers.
But the documents are pretty self
explanatory and it's, it's definitely, um,
it definitely,
I don't know if Mark Zuckerberg knows
that these things are happening,
but if he does, he was lying
under oath. Right. So wouldn't,
the sensible thing to do if you are mark
Zuckerberg would be make sure that you
don't really know what's going on at
your company so that when you get put in
the position where you're under oath,
you can basically say anything.
And I think this would
stand true for jacket,
Twitter and a bunch of these guys
if the buck never stops with you.
And I'm sure you saw, um, Jack from
Twitter on with Joe Rogan and Tim Pool.
And it was like, he just struck me as, oh,
I don't really know what's
going on with my company,
but that seems like it's by design. It's
not an accident. That's interesting. Um,
uh, there's a book by Blake Harris out
in the last couple of weeks about Palmer
Luckey and Facebook,
and I encourage you to read it.
It's unbelievable that this guy, uh, uh,
Palmer Luckey who founded the Oculus,
the virtual reality software was, uh,
was dealt with by Mark Zuckerberg
directly inside the company.
He was told not to be a Trump supporter,
him on the show actually. So, um, I,
I don't,
I don't know whether that's true or not.
I did see a Jack Dorsey,
uh,
he's never addressed
anything we've exposed,
they don't want to deal
with the actual evidence.
There's video tapes of Obenauf of a driver
was saying one strategy is to shadow
banned. I mean, there's, they don't
want to actually address the evidence.
They want to say, well,
they don't know what they're
talking about. Well, you know,
and by the way,
there is a difference between,
I think anytime you have human beings
in a room making content decisions,
subjectively you're going
to have these problems.
These are hard problems to solve.
But it goes back to the original point
of hiring hundreds if not thousands of
people do the content review.
I think at the end of the day,
if these companies don't
like an independent people
influencing the minds of
other people,
that's what this is really about.
And that would actually be okay if they
were transparent about it, sort of,
because then it would allow
competition to fill that void.
But this sort of neither here nor
there and instead of it seems to be the
problem. So, okay, so d boosting seems
to be the main problem with Facebook.
And that's interesting that
it was hitting Crowder videos,
Lauren and Shannon and a couple of
other people, and this means you're,
you're streaming, right? So this means
when he's streaming that the, the number,
it's just not going to feed,
is that
right? It's, it's when you're,
when you do a live stream video,
there are special tags, there are
special qualities in that live stream,
and they down rank the video,
they take away some of the
special qualities that make
it automatically show up
on other people's timelines according
to the insider that we spoke to.
The other thing about these videos
that are live streamers that they're
converted to text automatically
and machine learning goes
through the video and
identifies these keywords. So yes,
the video would be down ranked.
It would have its special
qualities taken away. And, uh,
I think that Crowder settled out
of court in 2016 with Facebook.
It's what he told me.
And I think that he's in the process of,
of doing some more litigation related to
some of the things they're doing to his
videos.
Yeah. Is there anything else that you
need to know on the Facebook front?
You've said they've gotten a
little bit better when it comes to,
they would ban people in suspend
people left and right all the time.
I used to have my, my friend Faisal Omar,
who's been on the show many times, who's,
uh,
an ex Muslim from,
from Iraq and really working
to secularize the Arab world.
I mean doing incredible, incredible
work. I mean this is a good man.
He would get banned all the
time. Right. And I would have,
I had a contact there so I was
able to help him get back on that.
Seems to be happening a
little bit less now. I logged
in there, the, the insiders showed
me how it works. There's it,
I guess what you call a task
function and um, and you know,
someone gets there. There are, there
are independent people in the company,
low level people who just make arbitrary
decisions to remove people and then
that's wrong and they shouldn't
do that. So what, so they're only,
there are adult supervision in the
room. There are, there are people,
there's like a conversation
thread under each task.
They convert these things
into what they call tasks.
And there are adults that say,
well that's no good.
And there relationships with a
lot of the publishers for um,
entities like such as your own and,
and,
and there was a relationship between a
sales rep at Facebook and there seemed to
be adult supervision.
But the problem is with the algorithm
side of things as far as I can see.
So He's part of it that the algorithm,
in many cases they will,
the algorithms were written by people,
you know, 10 years ago or 15 years ago,
probably aren't at the company anymore.
Nobody really like who really understands
what's going on with these algorithms.
Do the engineers at these companies even
have a sense of what's really going on
and how can they make sure that they're
not manipulated by the low level people
in? Well, one of the problems I have is a
reporter doing this is trying to, I mean,
I'm not a tech person.
I'm not a,
I don't claim to have any
special expertise is trying to,
people's eyes glaze over when you start
talking about machine learning and uh,
and,
and SSI livestream distribution.
So trying to get the people indignant
about something that they have no idea
what this means. But
yes, I think Danny Ben,
David wrote the algorithm at Facebook in
2017 than it was apparently intended to
address violence or suicidal content.
And we believe that it was a applied
to politics and it was used for ill.
That seems to be what
happened at Facebook.
So you're saying the road to hell is
paved with good intentions, right?
Is that what you're telling me?
Uh,
anything else going on in Facebook
that we need to know about it? And,
and do you sense that Zuckerberg may
be because of being hauled in front of
Congress will do anything?
I can tell you that everyone inside
the company knows what we did. And uh,
there's one,
I don't know how many 60,000 employees,
they all know exactly what we did.
And I think that when we
personalize it by going to the men,
went to the engineer's doors,
we went to,
we went to the train station where the
guy gets on the train every morning and I
interviewed him and he said, I fear for my
safety. He's like, I'm scared. I'm like,
you're scaring. I should be
afraid for my safety. I mean,
you guys are the ones spying on
us and taking our videos down and,
and not to that, but I'm going after
this trillion dollar company. Um,
but we personalized it.
And I think that there's a lot in,
since I released this tape a month ago,
there have been many people inside the
company that have approached me and I'm
trying to,
you know,
it's always the question of do you want
to wear a camera or do you just want to
feed me things anonymously?
My medium is video.
I think that there has to be video
because if we don't take these things,
no one will believe it.
So then the person has to basically
lose their job and I'll hire them.
And that's how our,
our model tends to work these days.
How do you make sure that when someone
reaches out to you that they're not just
trolling you like a triple agent?
Yeah.
Well basically that they would reach out
to you knowing that you throw up one,
one bad thing and there's
been little moments, yes, we
can get into yes. Um, that,
that's going to blow up all of the
other good work that you've done.
So there's high incentive for something
else. It's a, it's a risk. It's, I mean,
listen, what we do is very high risk
for many different reasons, which,
which we can get into I guess.
But what we do is extremely
risky and an undercover work,
you're going to get burned.
You try to use common sense.
There are things that we do. Ew. Ew, ew,
ew, ew, ew. V Eagle. Very carefully. You,
you do your due diligence.
Oftentimes they send you something.
There is something called tortious
interference with, uh, with, you know,
violating a nondisclosure
agreement. Um, uh, the, the,
it's a lot of complex legal analysis,
but essentially they have to tell us
something first and then we can tell them
to film what they have told us. So there,
you know, we have to be very careful and,
and we have been burned by the way,
and you probably knows about some of
those things, but for the most part,
we're 95 to 98% successful.
Not everything that people bring to us,
do we publish? Not Every secret
conversation that I've recorded,
do we publish?
I think it's the choosing to publish
something at the video that we've obtained
is really where the ethical
calculation comes in.